après x qui perd réaliste on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte 159,99 euros 160
euros
à ce prix là il va pas vous faire le
café et vous livrer les croissants et la
complète par contre je trouve que
[Musique]
vous n'avez demandé depuis quelques
temps et enfin regarder il est là
aujourd'hui je vous parle du samsung
galaxy j-6 qui est un téléphone d'entrée
de gamme de chez samsung et d'ici
quelques jours
restez avec nous parce qu'on va parler
aussi d'un smartphone de motorola
celui-ci là dans quelques jours et dans
quelques jours on va aussi parler du rx
17 neo 2 où peut on a parlé du pro il ya
pas longtemps maintenant au retour au
galaxy j-6 de cette année ce qu'on va
dire tout de suite on va l'ouvrir online
boxer on va regarder ce qui est un peu à
l'intérieur on a testé on va voir si les
coûts lourds hino voilà la bête alors
que le packaging est sympa j'aime
beaucoup cette couleur thé très tonique
très frais et très jeune ce modèle
uniquement pour les cartes sim
européenne voilà hop voilà la bête sans
pales de bon c'est pas les design les
plus dingues qui existent ne cesse
efficacement ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur de la boîte un guide de
prise en main on doit avoir la carte de
garantie enveloppe de charge des
écouteurs ici de quoi changer ces
petites bonnes est un câble
d'alimentation en micro usb et on a bien
évidemment de quoi ouvrir son tiroir de
capside format vraiment très compacte
franchement la prise en main est très
cool
vous le voyez rien et si vous avez un
capteur d'empreintes digitales bon alors
point un peu les gars tiff tout de suite
c'est que effectivement lorsque vous à
dire déverrouiller votre doigt va tout
de suite flirter avec l'appareil photo
vous allez forcément laissé des petites
traces d'empreintes dessus voilà ça
c'est un truc que j'aime pas trop où je
reproche souvent ces appareils là ça
aurait été bien de le mettre un peu plus
bas néanmoins les compacts mon doigt se
positionne très facilement dessus
la position du capteur me semble bien
c'est là paraît effectivement je trouve
ça bien aujourd'hui qu'il les dépenses
sur le côté ça évite notamment comme sur
le galaxy à 708 effectivement me reposer
sans doute là dessus
bon après c'est pas hyper hyper grave on
est 1 2 plastique du feu sont du fait
franchement ça va legault samsung
surbrillance là ça marche bien sur le
côté on a un bouton marche arrêt ici
c'est un haut parleur sur le côté triste
jack ça c'est cool micro usb
deux tiroirs ça c'est marrant là ici on
a une carte sim numéro un qui vient se
loger juste la carte sim et carte micro
sd vous avez ici vos boutons pour le
volume pour le monter pour le bc sur le
dessus il y a absolument rien votre
appareil photo
votre appareil photo un flash led design
plutôt efficace le poids franchement il
est pas très lourd il fait 154 g bon
maintenant on va l'allumer
vous avez un écran de 5,6 pouces avec
une résolution de 1480 par 720 pixels
c'est du hd plus ici pas de full hd
après de notre côté on est sur un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme le format
est bien c'est du 18 points 5/9 vous
êtes à 294 pixels par pouce la
résolution est correct c'est pas un truc
de dingue ça marche quand même
relativement bien ça c'est cool
bon ça va il ya du son c'est pas non
plus complètement fou ça crache pas de
tous les côtés comme je vous le disais
les haut parleurs est située juste là à
la différence de haut parleurs vous
pouvez si tu es là lorsque vous mettez
maintenant comme ça ça fait caisse de
résonance et ça vous envoie plus de
volume lassé par le cas mais brock face
à vraiment problématique
après x type est réaliste on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte 159,99 euros 160
euros
à ce prix là il va pas vous faire le
café vous livrer les croissants et la
complète par contre je trouve que le
rapport qualité prix est vraiment
vraiment vraiment honnête
l'écran super amoled fait le job
correctement le job il le fait très bien
dans cette gamme de prix
pour moi il est extrêmement bien
positionnée vraiment un point fort ce
smartphone et il n'a pas du tout à vous
chers par rapport à la concurrence
bien au contraire c'est vraiment un
atout majeur là dessus le jo est cool la
puissance les paroles mais ça marche
et en terme de performance je trouve
assez fluide pour la navigation là ça va
très bien et même lorsque vous jouez si
physiquement pour des jeux comme asphalt
titre oh ça marche très très bien
alors vous attendez pas à voir des
parties de foot iptv g avec de la
fluidité de fous là dessus c'est pas du
tout l'adn de ce smartphone la dalle de
7 bekale c'est bien au contraire d'avoir
des petits jeux ludiques pouvoir vous
marrer mais c'est pas non plus
j'ai complètement pété ma bagnole mais
c'est pas là dessus non plus vous allez
avoir les performances et une folle du
monde
d'un côté c'est pas ce qu'on lui demande
avec un exil aux 7870 cadencé jusqu'à
1,6 gigahertz 3 j g
c'est pas là dessus qu'on aura une
bécane de complète un truc qui va être
hyper puissant par contre dans cette
gamme de prix je trouve qu'il est
vraiment honnête vous avez un stockage
de 32 gigas qui pouvait monter qu'à 256
giga ça c'est aussi cool et honte à
l'autonomie je trouve vraiment bien
la batterie sur papier paraît pas énorme
3000 milliampères heures néanmoins c'est
pas du tout un smartphone qui est
énergivore
vous êtes tranquille une journée sans
aucun problème
lorsque vous allez jouer faire des
réseaux sociaux quelques e-mails des
sénès décidé savoir bon faut pas non
plus être hyper hyper vraiment faut pas
s'attendre à voir des trucs de dingue
mais c'est vraiment un point qui m'a
vraiment surpris là dessus je trouve que
l'autonomie est vraiment cool quand j'ai
vu marquer trois mille billions terreur
gym
ça va être un peu compliqué et au final
pas du tout autre point positif et
capteur d'empreintes digitales marche
très très bien je pose à peine mon doigt
tout de suite a dit oui pour ça c'est
vraiment une technologie qui est
maîtrisé et aussi la reconnaissance
faciale face unlock marche bien acheminé
en face il reconnaît directement mon
visage s'associent un point très positif
alors faut savoir quel par ailleurs vous
avez du bluetooth 4.2 du lfc vous
édition d'une prise micro usb donc ne
vous attendez pas à voir de la recharge
rapide tourner sur un android 8.0 oreo
vous avez la surcouche expérience lui à
9.0 enfin voilà ça fonctionne qu'en est
il maintenant de la partie photo vidéo
alors à l'arrière vous avez ici un
simple capteur ça ça vous aura pas
échappé
vous pouvez pas louper 13 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f
1.9 vous avez un autofocus dessus alors
vous avez un capteur de 8 mégapixels une
ouverture de f 1 point de f
on peut filmer max à l'avant et à
l'arrière en 1920 par 1080 à 30 images
par seconde
côté vidéo ça marche c'est pas non plus
un truc de fou ça fera largement la
sphère pour venir capter des souvenirs
là on est sur la caméra de sa fille et
maintenant on passe sur la caméra
arrière pour moi ce smartphone
je trouve que c'est un bon rapport
qualité prix dans cette gamme de tarifs
à l'organe a d'autres qui sont très bien
mais celui-là avec un écran super amoled
plus l'autonomie
il est vraiment dans la course vous avez
le mode automatique le mode beauté le
mode pro panorama nuit hd
tons riches bon why not c'est pas mal ce
vrai que ça fait un petit essai ça
marche pas mal
c'est pas complètement dans le non plus
autocollants pour pouvoir ajouter
effectivement des petits autocollants de
la réalité augmentée directement bon ça
c'est marrant c'est un truc qui marche
bien mode rafale
voilà y'a rien de bien bien dingo les
photos sont pas complètement folle ça
c'est une photo prise avec la caméra de
sel fille ça marche dès lors vous avez
la lumière ça fonctionne des photos un
prix standard
bon c'est pas complètement dingue hein
les couleurs sont parfois envoyés là
typiquement là dessus les couleurs sont
pas du tout du tout du tout hallucinante
je dirais que ça fait des photos qui
sont propres
c'est pas des photos complètement dingue
néanmoins vu le prix de l'appareil c'est
plutôt un excellent rapport qualité prix
pour 159 euros
maintenant dès lors que la lumière est
plus trop trop là il a vraiment vraiment
vraiment du mal
il rajoute beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit et après le rendu est vraiment pas
du tout kelly pour résumer ce smartphone
je trouve très bien par rapport à son
prix gros point positif c'est l'écran
super amoled la qualité toujours là sur
les noirs a fini sur des contrats ce
qu'ils sont
qui sont vraiment bien que vous avez une
vraie vraie belle qualité au niveau de
l'écran petit bémol sur l'écran bien
évidemment c'est du hd plus c'est pas du
full hd peut pas tout avoir dans cette
gamme de prix non plus autre point très
positif c'est la batterie l'autonomie
est franchement excellentes côté plutôt
cool c'est les photos lorsque vous avez
de la lumière si vous êtes en faible
luminosité
l'appareil va vraiment galéré c'est
vraiment pas un appareil tout est fait
pour faire des photos lorsque vous
sortez le soir vous allez faire la fête
entre amis pas du tout il faut que vous
ayez la lumière pour filmer des paysages
pour ramener des souvenirs ça marche pas
très bien alors attention les couleurs
vont pas être les plus contrastées c'est
pas hyper flatteur néanmoins ça
fonctionne ça fait la faire et ça c'est
aussi un point qui est franchement cool
je trouve bien en termes de performance
je trouve fluide les parties pib g avec
plein de potes dans des qualités dingue
là dessus très clairement fourbissent
c'est pas du tout un smartphone qui est
fait pour ça mais pour jouer à des jeux
type asphalte nitro ou des jeux pas trop
gourmands
dès qu'on décroche d'essayer ça vous
aurait absolument aucun problème ça va
très bien et après ce que vraiment il
permettre aux smartphones c'est qu'il
est franchement pas très épais qui est
très compact qui tient très très très
facilement dans la main par rapport à
aujourd'hui à des smartphones qui sont
de plus en plus grands là on est sur
l'écran de 5,6 pouces c'est cool point
un petit peu un petit peu bêtement
négatif c'est l'emplacement du capteur
d'empreinte dit
elle n'est pas hyper idéal on va
toujours flirté un petit peu avec
l'appareil photo dessus
bon voilà ça s'est une fois de plus du
point de détail après voilà je trouve
globalement bien je trouve que c'est un
smartphone lorsqu'on a un budget aux
alentours 150 euros c'est un smartphone
qui est très bien je pense que samsung a
bien réussi sa copie sur son âge ici de
2018 je trouve cool dites moi ce que
vous en pensez est ce que vous l'avez
acheté ce geste parce qu'il est déjà
sorti comment vous le trouvez ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter je
sais que vous avez des nombreux et
nombreuses à demander le test du gie 6
ça y est il est là il est beau il est
chaud et autres tant que je trouve
vraiment cool là dessus c'est la boîte
j'adore cette couleur ceci en est juste
magnifique voilà dites moi ce que vous
en pensez vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire je vous invite bien
évidemment à consulter ma playlist pour
découvrir tous les smartphones
smartphones du moment comparer vous
faire votre idée vous verrez ya vraiment
vraiment beaucoup de produits ça c'est
super cool et puis bien évidemment à
rester connectés parce que dès demain
aux autres rendez vous et vous allez
voir dès demain
normalement on devrait être à 100 mille
abonnés ça va être complètement dingue
je vous embrasse à demain ciao